[Music]
let's get the show on the road quick
10-minute game quick and
easy
2289 okay excellent so joined a long
time ago so looks like we're in for a
good game good luck to chess player
56123 and we are facing an alipin from
the black side I've recommended a couple
of different systems uh with black I've
kind of vacillated on what to make my
kind of official recommendation I feel
like going D5 and Knight F6 let's go for
this line this is what I've been playing
um lately in my own Blitz Games and it's
a pretty solid line okay so our opponent
plays D4 we play C takes D4 yeah so the
way our opponent plays it just kind of
gives us a a pretty favorable iqp
structure this is possible from the
white side but it's not particularly
ambitious if white plays Knight F3
believe it or not this is actually a
transposition to a caroan panov attack
like this position can occur via the
kokon move order as I'll show after the
game the obvious move here is Bishop G4
but Bishop G4 leads to a very forced
line where white responds with Queen B3
typically there's a bunch of Trades and
then the position liquidates into an
equal endgame so the downside of playing
this line with black is there are a
couple of these very drawish lines that
white can play to neutralize the Knight
F6 Knight F6 alipin uh we're going to go
E6 we're going to keep fire on the board
and we're going to keep some action
alive E6 is an alternative that the
downside of this move is obviously that
the bishop on C8 is kept outside of the
pawn chain the upside is that we keep
the Queens on the board and here we get
a very kind of classical iqp struggle
I've had a couple of positions on both
sides of the isolated Queen Pawn uh
throughout the speeduns and here we are
facing we are facing the isolated Queen
pawn and we have a relatively favorable
setup in the sense that we have complete
control of the square in front of the
pawn this is kind of the golden rule
when you're trying to assess uh an iqp
position first thing you look for is who
has control of the square in front of
the iqp if it's the side that's fighting
it then this Pawn is relatively
immobilized and it's it's harder to
shoot at a moving Target than a
stationary
Target okay so the second step toward
cons consolidating our positional
Advantage is probably to find suitable
arrangement for the bishop on C8 and we
don't have much of a choice because we
have a Pawn on E6 Knight E4 is a bit of
a weird move I'm not really sure what
our opponent wants so we're going to
follow through on our plan with B6 and
if we can Feen ketto the bishop and
maybe even get a rook to C8 we kind of
reach an ideal setup White's got to do
something relatively fast if he doesn't
then we develop all of our pieces and if
we can stabilize the Knight on D5 we
have a great version of the iqp
structure you our opponent is now
thinking I think some of you watching
are probably worried about like Knight
G5 ooh scary but we can just respond
with H6 I'm I'm not sure what the
followup is this Knight on e4 may look
intimidating and the prospect of Knight
G5 may look scary but there's nothing
Concrete in order to generate concrete
threats white probably has to build a
battery out of the bishop and the Queen
and if you know anything about iqp
structures then you probably know that
one of White's most typical plans is to
pile up against the H7 Pawn by
constructing a battery and when you
construct a battery um you generally
want the queen as the leading piece
because you want to threaten Checkmate
so the typical way of doing it is to
drop the bishop back to C2 and then to
have the queen take The Bishop's place
with Queen D3 but white has already lost
a little bit too much time uh to make
this happen if white plays Bishop C2
first of all we can play Bishop A6 and
we can take away the D3 Square second of
all even if we let white Play Bishop C2
and queen D3 we can simply meet that
with the move Knight C to B4 completely
disarming the battery so it's a very
cumbersome plan it takes like three
moves typically to set up the battery
and even if white does it's not like the
game ends immediately we can always play
G6 and we can blunt the effect of the
bishop and the queen Royal Fork ramble
thank you for the subs hopefully this
makes a certain degree of sense I'm not
going to go from like the very Basics
because I've had a couple of iqp games
already and remember that the basic
philosophy of the speedrun is that I
tend to match my in-game observations to
the current level that I'm at if you're
watching this and you're a relatively
newer player you might not be as
familiar with iqp positions and that's
okay just try to follow the game don't
worry too much about knowing all the
typical plans and ideas okay Knight G5
so our opponent kind of says all right
well I already put my knight on e4 I
might as well okay we can play G6 here
but I mean obviously the benefit of H6
is that it's a tempo move and we're
gaining more time time that we can use
to complete our development and start
putting pressure on the D4 pawn it feels
like our opponent is kind of losing the
threat of the game already he might not
be too much too familiar with iqp
structures yeah H7 is no longer a Target
that's true but the H7 square is still a
Target the point is not that there's a
Pawn on H7 even if there was a zebra on
H7 white would still try to Target that
square but by the time I mean white
doesn't even have the time to to drop
the bishop back anymore because
currently the Knight is hanging it's not
totally clear where to where to put the
Knight Knight H7 is probably asking for
trouble so our opponent goes all the way
back to E4 okay so we don't have to
think too long we can complete our
development with Bishop B7 I think it
would be a mistake for us to push F5
maybe some of you are like all right
let's go let's follow up on our previous
move but F5 is a very weakening move the
Knight on e4 is not bothering us in fact
it's kind of in the middle of White's
pieces it's actually hurting white more
than it's hurting us so F5 would merely
create an additional unnecessary Target
on E6 okay so now we enter the phase
where we kind of make small slow
improving moves and we take eventual
steps towards surrounding and winning
the isolated Queen Pawn but this process
is a long one it's a gradual one and
we're not out of useful improving moves
just yet so a move that we could throw
in
without thinking much as Rook to see it
we can just bring the Rook to the open
file this is a very flexible move we're
not doing anything concrete just yet in
some cases we're setting up ideas like
Knight B4 but above all we're just
getting the Rook to an open file Our
Queen can remain on it on its initial
Square for the time being because in the
future we might actually take the Knight
away from D5 and the queen will be
directly aiming at the big biggest
Target in White's position which of
course is the pawn on D4 now what you
should understand about blockades right
is that the point of a blockade is to
immobilize the target but eventually the
Knight is going to move away from D5
this is a temporary post eventually
we're going to want to win the D4 Pawn
the point as I think Larsson put it is
blockade a blockade is not like an end
in itself it's a means to an end you
blockade a pawn a lot of the time in
order to eventually win the pawn okay
Knight G3 so there's a couple of things
that come to mind here we can go Knight
C to B4 but then white will drop the
bishop back to B1 so if we're playing
that move we need a clear followup I
actually have a followup in mind this is
an idea that I have seen before so I'm
not generating this on my own we're
going to go Knight C to B4 and we're
going to try to put a knight on C2 and
the point of trying to put a knight on
C2 is not to Fork the two Rooks because
anytime a knight appears on C2 White's
going to be able to take it with the
bishop but what is White's main
attacking engine what is White's main
attacking piece it is in fact the bishop
on B1 without this bishop white is not
going to be able to build a battery
white is not going to be able to do
anything to harass our King in any way
so we need to add an attacker to the C2
Square well if I put it like that then
the move is obviously Queen C7 and the
crazy thing is that white is so pushed
back to the first rank that white is a
very hard time stopping the infiltration
of the Knight on C2 white cannot play
Rook E2 or actually white can play
rookie 2 I missed that amazingly white
actually can play rookie 2 because Queen
takes C1 there is a check on H7 but Rook
e 2 is also a very awkward move so we
can play Bishop A6 for instance and
white is already like borderline losing
white has to contort himself massively
to avoid losing material yeah so so Rook
e 2 is viable but it's doesn't solve all
of White's problems and allowing Knight
C2 is pretty disastrous from a
positional standpoint as well probably I
I would play Rook e to here yeah Knight
H5 our opponent is throwing himself onto
our King does this alter our plans in
any way not really very important to
understand a lot of newer players they
see a move like this and then they kind
of instinctively they want to react by
pushing the piece away like G6 but I
would hesitate to make any unnecessary
weaknesses and I would always ask like
is the piece actually doing anything is
it causing us direct discomfort now you
might say well what about a sack on G7
well none of this can possibly work
because White's got essentially no
pieces on the king side of course maybe
some of it will work but it's very
unlikely so we follow up on our plan
with Knight C2 you don't always need to
react defensively to moves like this you
can follow through on your plan I think
our plan is much stronger than whatever
it is that white is doing on the king
side this takes a certain degree of of
guts but it's like White's got nothing
going on on the king side and if white
plays Bishop take C2 we take with a
queen and we force a queen trade which
is also in our favor then we really
won't have to worry about anything that
happens on the king side and then we're
essentially positionally winning I think
if if white has to take on C2 we're
positionally winning so my guess is our
opponent is thinking about various
sacrifices desperation ideas but nothing
is going to work yeah another very
important detail some of you might be
noticing is that if white plays Queen D3
and says ahuh your ass is mine because
the Knight can't move because of there's
mate on H7 Queen D3 no White's ass is
actually RS because of Knight D to B4
forcing the queen away from the diagonal
okay there we go so as we predicted
white is going to just put on one last
desperation attempt and this type of
Hail Mary chess can be really dangerous
especially if it's orchestrated by good
players we need to be we need to be
balsy we need to be firm but we also
shouldn't be too arrogant and just grab
all of the pieces that are offered to us
the first first question is what do we
take which can be a very infuriatingly
hard question to answer now my instinct
is to play G takes H6 because the Rooks
are not really going anywhere we're not
worried about Bishop takes C T2 what
could be White's idea after GH well
probably it's to play Queen to D2 would
be my guess and then to send the queen
down to H6 and that would be genuinely
very very dangerous so give me a second
to figure this out takes Tak okay I
think I see a defense I think we start
with G takes H6 and often what tends to
happen is when your opponent throws his
pieces at you you need to do a little
bit of calculation you need to be very
concrete because at times there's no
safe option you have to open up your
king it's scary for two or three moves
but once you repel the initiative it's
over so here for instance I think we
have a very strong move that might not
be intuitive to people who are super
worried about Queen takes H6 you might
be thinking oh we're black is busted we
should go King H7 but King H7 is a
really inadvisable move it it self pins
the Knight you might say oh well what
about Bishop G5 and Bishop G5 is a very
Sound Idea except it runs into Knight
takes G5 and I think that's a possible
course of action you might say oh Bishop
G5 Knight takes G5 great white's no
longer threatening the H Pawn let's take
the Rook but that's a little bit too
messy I think the key to the position is
actually unless I'm blundering something
to play Knight takes E1 and it's rant on
a very important tactic if white plays
Queen takes H6 who can spot the winning
sequence it's not very hard if this move
is already played on the board but this
is what I'm talking about you have to
often find a two or three move defensive
sequence and then the attack is
completely shut down yeah we play Knight
takes F3 check G takes F3 and the queen
moves up to C1 again the C file is what
decides the game right when I played
Rook C8 might like did I see this when I
played Rook C8 no but this is why you
need to occupy open files with their
heavy pieces because of stuff like this
yeah Queen H6 Knight F3 gf3 Queen C1
check and we're forcing the queen trade
we're forcing the queen trade and it's a
check most importantly if it wasn't a
check well if it wasn't a check white
would have made on G7 but it would also
succumb to Bishop H7 check now if white
recaptures on E1 with his Knight then we
can already Play Bishop G5 so for
instance in this position we would not
want to go Queen C1 and blunder Bishop
H7 check
we would go Bishop G5 and the attack is
over Queen D3 we can go F5 and that's it
we're up a full rook and our opponent is
coming to terms with that right now he's
got 30 seconds so it's
over okay Queen H6 he goes down the line
and queen C1 check will lead to
resignation GG yeah good game short game
but I think a pretty instructive game
nonetheless a lot of people think that
the side which has the isolated Queen
Pawn has all the fun and that's not
necessarily the case it can be very very
dangerous to play with an isolated Queen
Pawn if you don't know the typical plans
and you don't know how to arrange your
pieces you can often get crushed in a
manner similar to this one so there's a
lot that I could talk about in the
general context of iqp positions I'm not
going to give you a three-hour lecture
on like typical ideas in the isolated
Queen Pawn I'm going to limit myself to
some relatively basic observations I'm
sure there are other iqp games that you
could look at in the speedrun I don't
remember off hand we have talked a lot
about this particular anti- alipin setup
with D5 e takes D5 Knight F6 we faced it
from the white side and in my opinion
white has two good moves uh White's two
good moves are queen A4 check and Bishop
B5 check both of these moves are aimed
at making it difficult for black to
recapture the D5 Pawn you could find a
theoretical exposition of this elsewhere
but suffice it to say in this video that
Bishop E5 check and queen A4 check are
both excellent moves that do give white
I think a slight Advantage with best
play by both sides so our opponent plays
D4 which is fine C takes C4 C takes C4
our opponent goes for a very kind of a
very straightforward continuation and I
mentioned after we had both developed
our Knights I mentioned that this could
transpose into a kacan what do I mean by
that well kacan goes E4 C6 D4 D5 and now
the panov attack is e takes D5 C takes
D5 and C4 and you can kind of see the
Contours of the iqp structure already
crystallizing now black typically plays
Knight F6 white typically goes Knight C3
Knight C6 and if white plays Knight F3
the main move for black is Bishop G4 um
if black plays E6 which is the second
most popular move here white can play C
takes D5 Knight takes D5 and voila voila
we've transposed to the game all right
via a caroan seemingly completely
different opening but that's the magic
of Chess two caroan and Sicilian can
transpose into each other under the
right
circumstances um by the way this
position can also be reached via a nimzo
Indian move order which might be even
crazier to you but you can get iqp
positions also from a Rubenstein
variation white can play like this and
for example not an exact transposition
but you can get this type of structure
in one of the main lines of the
Rubenstein variation D5 Bishop D3 C5
this is like the typical Pawn Cube for
example Knight F3 Knight F3 castles
castles and already if black wants uh
the main move is Knight C6 but if black
wants he can get uh an isolated Queen
Pawn structure boom there you go here's
another version of an iqp structure so
IQs can arise out of a variety of
different openings chances are that you
have somewhere in your opening
repertoire where you're either playing
against an isolated Queen Pawn or you're
playing with an isolated Queen Pawn the
other most popular misconception is
people ask like is the iqp good or bad
it depends entirely on the type of
position that you get generally it's
dynamically balanced like both sides of
their chances in a lot of iqp positions
but largely it depends on where the
pieces are placed which side is more
active and the other factors in the
position you can't make a a judgment
call on whether the iqp is good or bad
it's a meaningless question going back
to the
game as I mentioned if we play Bishop G4
this transposes directly into the main
line of the panoff if black plays Bishop
G4 here this is the kacan move order
white plays C takes D5 Knight takes D5
and the Annoying move is Queen to B3
which leads to a forced essentially a
forced drawing line black plays Bishop
F3 white plays uh G takes F3 E6 Queen
takes B7 this is not that important at
the end of this forcing line the Queens
are traded the knights are traded and
you get this very interesting endgame
which has occurred thousands of times
and is incredibly well studied and it's
very well known that the position is
equal now it's actually black who has an
isolated Queen Pawn White's got the
damaged Pawn structure on the king side
but black is experiencing long-term
problems uh with King safety because
once white plays Bishop B3 and castles
Queen side it's not entirely clear where
black should hide the king if you put it
on the E file well White's going to get
Rook to E1 if you put it on the C file
similarly white can easily get a rook to
C1 so white has the easier access to
open files that's why black typically
gives a check on B4 and quickly tries to
get his own Rooks to uh the important
open files but this is considered to be
dead equal most games that enter this
line end in a draw and I didn't want to
to get this this end game I assumed that
my opponent knows it pretty well which
is why in this position I decided to
play the more traditional isolated Queen
pawn move which is E6 okay hopefully
that explanation made some sense all
right so Bishop D3 is very standard this
is where typically the bishop is
developed uh Bishop B7 castles castles
and this position has occurred well over
a thousand times from many different
openings over 5,000 times in my database
uh on Drake and S like almost all the
top players have had this position with
one side or the other and Knight E4 is
not a very good move I think this is
already a major step in the wrong
direction white is displaying a
fundamental lack of knowledge of how to
play these positions you do not want to
leave the Knight on D5 alone if you
leave this Knight alone then black is
just completely fine so the main move
here is Rook to E1 the main move here is
Rook to E1 which is just kind of a
flexible improving move black is waiting
white is waiting for black to put his
cards on the table but there is a
concrete idea this is prophylactic you
are defending against the move B6 who
can tell me why why is B6 now an
inadvisable move for black this can be
hard to figure out if you're not
familiar with this type of position but
see if you can figure this out on your
own white to play and get a big
Advantage it's not it's not game over
but it's it's it's an advantage for
white yeah so exactly so Knight takes D5
Queen takes D5 which is the way that you
want to
recapture and now Bishop E4 is
incredibly unpleasant this is the point
of Rook to E1 and suddenly black is just
not in time if you give black one more
Tempo if we're able to play Bishop B7
we're chilling but here white is able to
win material with Knight E5 forcing
black to take on E5 and this is just a
clean extra exchange for
white so for that reason black is forced
to play e takes D5 but this also does
not solve Black's problems because white
can play Queen to C2 foring the Knight
and the pawn on H7 Queen C2 uh you might
say oh what about Knight B4 but this
does not work out tactically Bishop H7
check King H1 Queen B1 and if black
plays G6 trapping the bishop white sacks
it on G6 which is actually very very
common this is a very common way of
dealing with the move
G6 and white just gets a massive attack
here this is actually winning for white
yeah I still see two games in the
database both of them Bishop F5 Queen H5
check yeah one guy played Bishop a H7
and here the best move is actually
Bishop G5 trying to clear space for the
Knight to jump into G5 so we could
analyze this position but the fact of
the matter is that white has three pawns
for a piece and white has a longlasting
and Massive Attack on the king with the
Rook coming into E5 there's too many big
squares for black to hold on to okay so
you shouldn't be too concerned with this
the point is Rook E1 is a good move that
prevents B6 so after Rook E1 Black's
main move there's a lot lot of moves
here that GMS have played the most
popular move is Bishop to F6 putting
pressure on uh the D4 Pawn if white
plays Knight E4 which is the tempting
move black can actually play Bishop
takes D4 this works out for black and we
win the pawn this is actually a very
sharp line white plays Queen H5 the game
continues but black is considered to be
fine here after
H6 so for this reason most people
actually put the bishop on e4 adding
more pressure to the Knight on D5 this
is the main move now how do most GMS
play here most popular move is Knight C
to E7 adding a Defender to the Knight
now typically white plays Queen to D3
building the battery and this is not the
best battery it's preferable to have the
queen in front of the bishop but this is
the next best thing because you are
attacking H7 and you're provoking a
weakness if black plays G6 then this
very seriously weakens the dark squares
obviously around the King and Bishop H6
is a very unpleasant move to have to
deal with so most of the time Black Goes
H6 defending in a more in a less
weakening way but now white can throw
the Knight on to E5 and white is getting
very very active black can play Bishop
D7 and the position is approximately
equal a lot of the time what happens if
both sides are demonstrating knowledge
of how to play this properly what often
happens is that there's some sort of a
big trade on D5 and it leads to some
sort of an equal position so Knight C5 e
E5 the structure has shifted from an iqp
structure to symmetrical now white can
play Knight takes Bishop Queen takes
Knight by the way D takes C4 would be a
horrible blunder because this is a check
so know you have to recapture on D7
white plays Bishop F3 and maybe white is
a tiny bit better because White's got
the bishop pair but on the other hand
the D4 Pawn is a long-term Target Queen
to F5 and the position is equal if black
is accurate
here okay so this is just one of a
million possible
lines um Rook e one is not forced Bishop
F6 is not forced a lot of players they
go Knight to F6 in this position that's
the second most popular move just
dropping the Knight away and adding an
attacker on the D4 Pawn but here I'm
pretty sure white is considered to be
slightly better and the main move here
is A3 this is a very old position first
occurred in the game Zabo uner
1954 and what's crazy is that the Zabo
uner game both of them were very strong
European GMS of the 1950s llo Zabo from
Hungary Wolf Gang gunser from East
Germany or West Germany I don't remember
no I think West Germany uh big big GM in
the 50s and 60s this game reached uh
this position via the nimzo Indian move
order so just remember this position
hold it in your mind
the actual unuk Zabo game went D4 Knight
F6 C4 E6 you're like okay and kind of
how I demonstrated Knight F3 no sorry
Queen's gambut declined D5 Knight C3 C5
semi to rush another opening that can
yield iqp structures CD Knight D5 now
the main move here is E4 but Zabo played
the more conservative line E3 Knight C6
Bishop D3 CD Ed there we go the
structure crystallizes Bishop E7 castles
castles Rook e one Knight F6 A3 there we
go so seemingly unrelated opening and
yet we get the same exact position so
how did that game continue uh Zabo won
that game Let's uh let's let's take a
look at the original game in this line
uh uner played B6 which is totally
reasonable now Zabo played actually
there's a game now earlier than zabu
naidorf had the white pieces and British
I am Harry Golem back had the black
pieces white won that game also another
different opening but in the Zabo inser
game Bishop G5 Bishop B7 now what would
you do here with white let's see who's
been paying attention to my exposition
of the typical plans and setups for
white how does white add pressure on
Black's position here like what would
you do here with white road to FM got it
Bishop C2 now it's time to execute the
typical plan by rearranging the bishop
and the Queen and incidentally this is
why the move A3 is played so that once
you complete the transformation black
does not have the move Knight to B4
which actually I had in the game that's
why you put the pawn on A3 so unuk said
nope I am not letting you put your queen
on D3 but this is kind of an awkward
move now the Knight on C6 has lost a
Defender so Zabo plays Queen D2
connecting the Rooks logical Rook C8 by
uner also logical kind of like the move
I played in the game Queen F4 I like
this maneuver the queen is probably
sliding over to H4 adding an attacker to
H7 and the problem that black
experiences in a lot of these positions
is that if you play H6 under the wrong
circumstances white will obviously Play
Bishop H6 and this is just losing on the
spot here the Knight on F6 temporarily
holds the Checkmate but there's just
nothing that black can do white is just
going to lift The Rook up to E3 and then
move the Knight away and then mate you
on G3 okay so so this is what you need
to be very careful about um unuk played
Rook E8 now Rook ad1 look how patiently
Zabo is playing already Black's position
sucks and this is actually a perfect
illustrative game because black plays H6
now Bishop takes H6 was winning
according to the engine but Zabo plays a
different line he was a very positional
player he didn't like too many tactics
he plays Bishop F6 Bishop F6 and you
might say what is he doing giving away
the dark squ Bishop but this is now the
main idea of or one of the main ideas of
the side that has the isolated Queen
Pawn under the right circumstances you
want to do what and the circumstances
are perfect for white to do this thing
what are we talking about yeah D5 if
white can push the iqp forward it often
leads to an explosion and this explosion
favors the side that has the more active
pieces clearly white has the more active
pieces here and D5 wins the game very
quickly now Bishop C there's DC
important detail now both of these
pieces are
hanging Queen F6 the line doesn't end
Queen F6 white to play what do you do
how do you win the game here good little
exercise not super tactical wow Harry
golumbeck is a distant relative somebody
in the chat says that's pretty
incredible Queen to E4 very calm sliding
the queen to uh the battery square and
this is going to be Force mate very
lovely Force mate Rook to D7 mate in
this line so black loses the bishop on
C3 um so for this reason unuk was forced
to accept the trade e takes D5 now Rook
takes C8 Rook takes Queen takes C8 and
Zabo plays Queen to F5 nasty little move
and a very instructive move he actually
does not recapture on D5 most of you
would play Knight takes D5 here
automatically which is very unconvincing
because black can play Bishop takes B2
and it's anybody's game but Queen F5 is
a good idea to remember when there is a
bishop on F6 a queen on F5 in
conjunction with a bishop that con that
that bookends the battery is very
powerful because black cannot go G6 and
because black cannot go G6 he has to
allow often times a devastating check on
H7 in the game uner played Bishop C3
Queen H7 King f8 BC and White's attack
is decisive Knight E5 Knight D4 lovely
move heading to F5 Knight G6 h H4 top
engine move by Zabo trying to force the
Knight away from G6 so that you could
deliver a check on E1
H5 Bishop
F5 Rook takes C3 Knight E6 check this is
GM level tactics here F takes C6 Bishop
G6 now if Queen E7 then Queen h8 is mate
so black has to go to C6 check here
check here Rook E1 setting up a decisive
check on E5 Bishop C8 now Zabo simply
grabbed the pawn on H5 and he won the
game in a couple moves here here here
here just piling up on the pawn now he
pushes his
passer and he won the game after here
here here and here unuku resigned
because the Queens are traded and white
promotes the H1 now I went very quickly
through the second half of the game
because it's not it's not relevant to
our conversation it is obvious that
white won the opening battle in that
game and there's a lot of model games
that are shown to illustrate the power
of uh this Pawn push to D5 one game that
was shown to me and I I I saw this game
in an old book on on isolated Queen Pawn
let me see if I can find it it's Dava
against C so this game actually also
came from an alipin and even if even if
you don't play lines that involve
isolated Queen Pawn you shouldn't just
like glaze over at this cuz maybe one
day you will and it's just good to
understand other structures that even
that the ones that you don't play CU
that's how you enrich you can borrow
ideas from a structure that you don't
necessarily play then you can that's
that's how you become more well-rounded
as a player so this game actually
started out as an alipin some sort of a
weird line again you got the iqp
structure and this game is pretty famous
because white carried out an idea that
also constitutes one of the sort of main
ideas in iqp structures Queen E2 Bishop
B7 Rook D1 so all pretty standard stuff
and black plays a very bad move black
voluntarily plays G6 black voluntarily
plays G6 this is a very weakening move
and white says to himself oh it would be
very nice if we could Now open up the
center with D5 but obviously you can't
really go D5 immediately black just
plays e takes D5 so white carries out a
very famous maneuver that allows them to
prepare D5 who can tell me what white
plays so most of you are probably
thinking oh let's go Bishop C4 and
prepare it with the bishop and you have
the right idea but Bishop C4 runs into
the annoying move Knight A5 can we make
a more flexible move yes Bishop to B1
the point is you're getting the bishop
to A2 and that is how you're going to
prepare D5 and if Black Goes Knight A5
here you can just go B4 and Chase the
Knight back to C6 so in the game this
works to Perfection because black just
ignores the idea white pushes D5 the
trade happens and Black's position just
collapses because black has too many
weaknesses is here and white is way too
active Queen B8 sorry Queen B8 Bishop H6
is very strong and black is already
busted because no matter what black does
there's either going to be this
Checkmate or there's going to be
something something is going to give
here black plays Knight D4 and just
gives away a piece Bishop f8 Bishop B3
white white one very kind of textbook
game and this is like one of the two
main ideas on the white side of the iqp
uh which is to prepare D5 the other one
is to attack the black king on the king
side okay so of course like I'm giving
you model games from from the white side
from the the side that has the iqp and
I'm referring to it as the white side
but of course the you could have an
isolated Queen Pawn with the black
pieces it's it's not color dependent um
you might say well what aren't there
model games from the other side like am
I suggesting that the side with the iqp
wins more games again not necessarily
I'm just taking the iqp side for a bit I
can give you just as interesting of
instructive games from the other side
and the one game that comes to mind is
karpov kcho this is considered to be a
model game for fighting against the
isolated Queen Pawn let me see if I can
hunt it down really quickly yeah kpov
kpov actually won that game so I've
shown this game before on my stream and
like other speedruns and stuff this was
carpov or k kov during their world
championship match in 1981 four years
after their famous world championship
match in bagio City the controversial
one this was a queen's gamma declined so
here we got the isolated Queen Pawn
structure and the way karpov won is just
by exchanging all of the pieces he
exchanged all of the pieces and the more
exchanges that happen the less possible
it is for the side with the isolated
Queen Pawn to generate attacking ideas
and so often times the more significant
the weak Pawn becomes a carpa plays
Knight H5 just trading Bishops pretty
soon after he trades Knights kchoi
offers the trade himself more trades
happen and kcho just kind of stumbles
into this really really bad position now
he's got no attacking chances and he
still has is still saddled with this
weak pawn and notice how karpov has
completely blockaded the square in front
of the pawn he's not permitting D5 at
all pretty soon after yeah he triples on
the defile and he wins the game
eventually kcho succumbs and he trades
the last pair of pieces and carpov
eventually wins it's very instructive to
see how he does it but we're not going
to bog ourselves down to this right now
he wins the
game um can I show this from Black's
point of view I could but that's not
really the point we're not going to sit
down and analyze this game for 30
minutes although we could what I'm
trying to show is that it's not like the
side with the isolated Queen Pawn wins
more games or it's more fun to play with
the iqp the side that plays against it
can also score some very instructive
points and if you're playing against the
isolated Queen Pawn your checklist
involves blockading the square in front
of the pawn and if you can orchestrate
trades particularly if you can trade
queens that benefits you if you can
trade your knight for the light squir
Bishop that's often a favorable trade as
well that's actually what we tried to do
during the game so back to the game
white played Knight E4 pretty bad move
because it doesn't do anything it it
doesn't prevent us from completing our
development now Knight G5 H6 wasting
more time
wasting more time our opponent goes back
and just gives us like three extra Tempe
I'm actually curious if I played this
correctly I'm going to run this on the
engine Knight E4 Bishop B7 already black
is better Rook E1 Rook C8 is correct
Knight G3 Knight B4 is liked by the
engine and after Bishop B1 Queen C7 it's
already plus two to already here white
is losing the only move that kept white
in the game was Bishop to E4 all right
so you had to abandon your hopes of a
battery and just say okay I'm at least
going to keep the bishop on a more
active position yeah so Bishop E4 kept
white in the game yeah so Bishop E4 if
Black Goes Queen C7 here which we would
have here white can play Bishop to
D2 this is a move that white didn't have
in the game and if we play Knight
C2 white has Rooks C1 so this was the
way for white to stay in the game now
what should black do what should black
do in this position you might say oh
black has already blundered but no in
fact this is the correct line how does
black get a stable Advantage here yeah
Knight takes E1 so you actually give up
the queen but you get two Rooks for it
now you play Knight takes F3 check Queen
takes F3 Rook takes E7 and black is
better the two Rooks are slightly better
than the queen but white retains some
attacking chances white retains the game
goes on essentially uh so the engine top
move is H4 here which is a really hard
move to make not really sure what the
the point is F5 Bishop D3 and the game
goes on goes on white is surviving in
the game if white tries to do the same
thing well obviously you can't because
the Rooks don't jump over Bishops so
after Bishop B1 Queen C7 I think the
game is essentially over the only move I
think was rookie to this was White's
last chance and here the computer line
is very instructive you start with
Bishop A6 forcing Rook D2 now black has
an excellent move who who can tell me
what it is actually two excellent moves
both of them are aimed at the same thing
and logical thinking will lead you to
the right move here yep Idol CS gets one
of them King to h8 is one of the two
moves now you're simply expanding the
threat to the bishop um why was Queen
take C1 not possible it was because of
this discover check what is the root of
the Discover check well we can take away
the root of it or we can cut off the
diagonal even better is to play F5
because because here we also take away
the E4 Square from White's Bishop so the
bishop on C1 is literally trapped the
only move for white is A3 you have to
Counterattack a piece Queen C1 ab4
Bishop B4 and black is just crushing in
this position black is just crushing
because if you play Rook takes Bishop
white black obviously plays Bishop takes
rook and White's collapsing the computer
kind of stays in the game but this is
this is not very good okay Knight H5
Knight C2 is just game over Bishop takes
H6 desperation if I was playing white I
I mean I would just bite the bullet and
go into this end game as nasty as it is
at least white can keep defending but I
mean who would want to be in this who
would want to suffer in an end game like
this according to the computer it's
minus two minus two and a half but I
think in human terms this is even more
nasty this is just lost my pie are
getting in classic example of a position
that the computer can probably save but
if you have the this with white you just
hate your life you're just
miserable okay so in the game Bishop H6
GH and then the final test right was
this position after a queen D2 the
interesting thing is that there are
according to the computer there are four
moves that keep a decisive Advantage we
played the best move Knight takes C1
this wins immediately Bishop G5 is also
winning as I mentioned in the game this
is probably also winning but it's
significantly more Messi what are the
other winning moves here the other
winning move is Knight F6 which is a
very engine like move allowing Queen H6
and actually going after the Knight so
you can take away the Knight on H5 and
the Knight on C2 takes away the bishop
so black is winning and the last winning
move is Knight F4 this is just pure
computer chest this did not occur to me
at all Knight takes F4 Knight takes E1
it's also the least convincing win
because white can recapture on E1 and
here black is only up in exchange black
is is still winning but you know some
work remains to be done but if you find
the most accurate win at the very start
you often eliminate all resistance
Knight takes
E1 if white would have played Knight
takes E1 in the game our opponent just
lost
immediately what would have been our
response here black to play what is the
what is the most clinical most clinical
way to end the game yeah Bishop G5
Bishop G5 now ends the game very easy
move white can threaten checkmate but
it'll be the last time that white
threatens Checkmate this game because we
just push F5 that's it we are upper Rook
there is no attack white can resign and
white can't even get the bishop out
because we now jump to B4 with the other
Knight so so in this game you could see
how quickly like if white doesn't do
anything and that's literally our
opponent just went back and forth black
lays on the pressure very quickly once
you complete your development as black
and you get your heavy pieces to good
squares white has to generate activity
um otherwise you're going to get
massacred and that's what happened in
this game so hopefully this was a decent
overview of typical iqp plans of course
I barely scratched the surface there's a
million more games I could show but it's
getting late and uh I think that's good
enough for one video thank you I hope
you enjoyed good game to my opponent
yeah we keep our climb going to 2400 see
you guys
later